There are some default behaviors on
the street view panorama object that you
can override, if you like.
By default, street names
are written on the panorama.
Zoom gestures to zoom in and
out are available and
user navigation is enabled.
You can check and
set each of these using the following.
For street names,
you can call isStreetNamesEnabled, and
this will return a true or a false.
To set the street name,
you can call setStreetNamesEnabled.
And you pass that ability in true or
false to turn street names on or off.
For zoom gestures,
you call isZoomGestureEnabled
to check if it's on or off and
that will give you a true or a false.
And similarly,
you call setZoomGesturesEnabled and
pass that ability to turn them on or
off.
For user navigation,
you check isUserNavigationEnabled,
and this will return a true or a false.
And you call SetUserNavigationEnabled
to turn it on or
off, passing an ability true or false.
It's as simple as that.
Let's take a look at what this will
look like in an application, and
we'll see what it looks like with
street names on and streets names off.